let's bring in now father Dave Dwyer CSP
a priest in the Archdiocese of New York
and host of the busted halo show and
co-host of conversation with cardinal
Dolan both on Sirius XM radio and rabbi
Evan Moffett rabbi at Congregation
Macomb salal lakeside in the Chicago
suburb of Highland Park Illinois father
and rabbi good morning and thank you so
much for being here good morning happy
Easter and good taste luck and wonderful
to have you both after we've just heard
from Franklin Graham a message of hope
standing there father to you first in
New York Central Park you think about
the backdrop to his message the
Samaritan's Purse a field hospital set
up there 14:10 68 beds 10 ICU beds
you've got health care professionals
that are treating kovat 19 patients in
those tents right behind him and the
chaplains from Billy Graham's rapid
response team are in there trying to
deliver that same message of hope your
takeaway from Reverend Graham's message
well a couple of passages that he
preached on from the New Testament
Scriptures are special to me as well I
absolutely agree that this is a time
unique like no other perhaps even in the
history of the world where we are in a
storm and we're in a storm all together
this is unprecedented and unique
obviously in a in a tragic way but
perhaps there is a way that we as a
human family all as children of God
created in the image and likeness of God
can realize are bonded together necess
said in his Easter message that this is
no time for indifference because the
entire world is suffering so the message
of hope is one that as Reverend Graham
preached that God desires our healing
God desires us to be saved to be
completely united with him and Easter is
a day particularly that we recall and
celebrate that typically we're used to
celebrating it together I mean we'd
rather see Wright and Central Park we'd
rather see a big wide
shot like at the Simon Garfunkel concert
that I was at in 1980 where it's just
packed with people and everyone's like
yes Jesus Easter yes God loves us we
can't experience one another or God in
that way this Easter but there are so
many people around the world who don't
have a click their heels happy joyful
time any time let alone this time of
year I believe this unites us with them
perhaps uniquely for the first time
rabbi it's such an important message and
as you heard Reverend Graham say at the
end there who knows what next week holds
we don't know there's such great
uncertainty right now and at a time
where so many are struggling medically
you've got kovat 19 patients all over
the world who are looking for that
message of hope you have also those who
are in isolation who are lonely today
what is your message oh wow it's so true
my message actually goes back I was very
moved by Reverend Graham sermon thinking
of darkness I thought of the plagues the
plagues that God inflicted upon Egypt
that ultimately priests aged the Jewish
people walking across the Red Sea to
freedom and when they were walking
across the Red Sea they didn't know what
came next either they were walking into
the wilderness they had trust and God's
promise and I think that's my message
for people we we may be in a kind of
physically dark place right now we can't
be with one another but spiritually this
country is stronger than ever it's truly
amazing how people have reached out to
one another I just came across recently
this quote from GK Chesterton a great
Catholic theologian that America is a
nation with the soul of a church we have
an extraordinary soul in our country and
people have been reaching out to one
another supporting one another guiding
one another I can't tell you how strong
I mean my community feels stronger than
it's ever been and I think that's
because even in this time of darkness
it's brought out the best within us
rabbi that's such an uplifting message
and when we all need to hear this
morning and and father it reminds you of
what we've been seeing not just in New
York City
this is spread to suburbs all over the
country and other metropolis is but
people raising their windows shouting
out you know applauding the health care
workers on the front lines
firefighters lining the streets to say
thank you and that that sense of unity
is what we all need to get us through
this father well and if you look at and
I hope rabbi will agree with me really
the message of both halves of the Bible
the Hebrew Scriptures what we sometimes
call the Old Testament and that which
talks about Jesus and the Christian
community in the New Testament if one
had to boil it down to one singular
message particularly the Covenant notion
of the Old Testament it is that we are
people together and that this notion of
it's just me or even just me and God
which quite frankly but a lot of us tend
to think about in terms of our faith or
a religion but you can't get through
very much certainly of the Old Testament
or parts of the New Testament like the
Acts of the Apostles or even the way
that Jesus gathered people around him
and the Gospels and and continue to
think that this is just a singular
enterprise that community as you just
put it community is really what faith is
all about it's it's tempting to think of
it as what can I do to punch my ticket
so that I or maybe even my immediate
family can have eternal life or
something like that but primarily the
message we see from our God the God of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob the god of Jesus
is that it is all of us together that
God embraces us as a people not as a
person and another person another person
it is about togetherness and community
such as actually Pope this morning
calling for victory of love over the
root of evil calling for a contagion of
hope or perhaps rabbi that was an
observation oh yeah it is it's an
observation and I love what father just
said about togetherness and you know the
truth is God speaks to us in different
ways in different times and as I think
about Passover Passover is the oldest
religious ritual in the Western world in
a way I mean it goes all the way back to
Egypt where the ancient Israel
celebrated Passover the night before the
final plague and through extraordinary
times and difficult times and
experiences we've always celebrated
Passover it's evolved you know the way
Passover was celebrated in 13th century
Spain is different than 20th century
America and different from today so many
people use zoom and different
technologies to connect us on Passover
God still speaks to us wherever we are
however we are and that's the beautiful
part about our faith God is with us even
as we adapt to hear God's message for
our world that's amazing you look at
Palm Sunday and the numbers of people in
this country and around the globe that
did log on to those online services
because they are so hungry for worship
and and to celebrate their faith bring
back in father Dave Dwyer and Rabbi Evan
Moffett thank you so much again for
staying with us and rabbi if I could
start with you first going back to the
Pope's message something he said that
was so important probably resonates with
so many right now that while we can all
look at the good that has come from this
where we're hunkered down with our
families spending more time with our
children than we ever have turning to
faith
the economic hardship is big you look at
here at home in the United States 17
million people have lost their jobs over
the last three weeks that economic
hardship could have lasting effects what
is your message to those who may be
losing hope or faith as they don't have
a paycheck coming in right now
well my first message is that we're with
you we understand we're here I think
that I've certainly felt it in my
congregation talk to people and the
other it's really just I'm here we're
here to help you and also the spirit of
generosity has been enormous
a few days after of the shelter-in-place
order was put in Illinois we sent out a
message of the congregation asking for
donations to help those in need and
literally within the first four hours of
the email several tens of thousands of
dollars came in from people seeking
to hell mothers so I think that there is
a feeling of generosity and support and
that we're all in this together you know
right before this happened we've been in
such politically polarized times and we
we almost felt that life and death
depended on one particular argument over
another and now we know that we're all
in this together Republicans Democrats
people of different races ethnicities
we're all in this together so I think
it's actually even though we're
experiencing deep hardship we do feel a
sense of human connection and kinship
that I haven't seen in a long time
father final message to you there you go
back to Franklin Graham's message from
Central Park a moment ago talking about
a storm that has gripped the world he
said quote Jesus is the hope that the
world is looking for leave us off with
your message this morning on this Easter
Sunday well if you don't mind I'll take
a little borrow a little bit more from
Pope Francis loved Franklin Graham's a
message but Pope Francis in his homily
was preaching about what we hear from
the scriptures on Easter Sunday
interestingly we don't even when we can
come to church we don't come to church
to hear like a big Disney ending Jesus
doesn't like jump out of the tomb ago
hey guys you're all good we actually
conclude the Easter service merely with
the empty tomb and we hear the story of
the women who are the first to gather
there at Christ's tomb and they think
and they pass on the message to the
other disciples that it seems like all
hope is lost
it seems like this is the darkest hour
it seems like there is no light after
this we know of course that that is not
true and the message of Easter even even
if right now we're on the part of the
page that is just empty tomb we know
that the true message that God loves us
and God desires to heal us and to save
us is the message of Easter that Christ
does in fact rise and light comes into
the world and all hope is not lost this
is not our darkest hour this is the dawn
of Easter father David Dreier and rabbi
Evan Moffett we really appreciate both
of you coming on our special this
morning
thank you